hey everybody welcome to Fantasy Valley
part 9 in this video I'll be working on
a Japanese teahouse and a restaurant
around it and in the first half of this
video I'll be making the building itself
and in the second half we'll get into
path elements and details in the
surrounding area and this is a very
slow-paced episode in a sense that it's
just sped up twelve times as usual but I
didn't get that much work done at least
I didn't get as much done as I would
usually want to do and this goes for
pretty much all of the episodes so far I
have underestimated how much time much
of the things that I've been doing take
somehow and while this isn't really too
big of a problem right now it just means
that instead of the two episodes that I
think I said quite a while ago that it
would take before I went into the
facades around the lake here it's gonna
take four episodes which is double the
amount of time but not too big of an
issue and if I don't manage to finish it
I'll just be doing it in time lapses and
go on to the next area
after that the problem that I have as
you might be able to guess right now is
that I'm not really on a great schedule
when comparing like the current dates
and the amount of time that I still have
until the beta comes out approximately
because nobody has an exact idea but so
far just making this small part of the
park has already been taking a lot of
time and because of that I'm gonna
change my planning a little bit we're
not gonna head into the Southeast Asian
part of the park or the Arabian part of
the park after this but instead I want
to focus on the three major parts which
other parts that you can see from the
lake and which all have their own kind
of Rini so this area for instance has
that mountain with the pagoda but I'm
gonna have a big castle with a village
in the European section which is like
another central part of the park and in
the American section we'll have some
kind of temple sort of thing which is
also gonna be very central and if I have
time left I'll get into the areas in the
corners which are the smaller areas and
kind of tucked away but if I don't have
time for that anymore then everything
issues can be those major three areas
just because I'm not really sure how
much time
I really have to finish my stuff and
like I said in the last episode I I do
hope to make a lot more stuff than I
have been recently and I can definitely
do so it's not that I'm gonna you know
get lower quality videos or just
completely forget about everything else
in my life but I just think I can do
things quite a bit faster than we're
doing right now but we'll see how that's
gonna work out anyway the only real
effect that that has is that I'm right
now we're trying to get the Asian area
done and after that we'll head into
Europe and see how that's gonna work out
anyway back to what I'm doing right here
this building was kind of tricky and I
wanted to throw it off grid a little bit
and actually play with these different
layers because there's a typical thing
of Asian architecture where the lower
floors are wider than the upper floors
and that goes for the roofs as well and
it's something which I haven't really
done so far like the pagoda every floor
of a pagoda should normally be a bit
smaller than the floor underneath it
which I haven't really done so far since
you know everything within the building
is still on the grid and it's really
hard to get those very minuscule kind of
differences between the floors
especially since I wanted to make my own
roofs here but here I wanted to
experiment with that a little bit and
get a second roof on the tea house with
a slightly smaller floor and a unless
broad wide roof on top of it as well and
that is what I was doing here which is
the reason why the building actually is
made out of different buildings so that
I could actually have a one and a half
tile wide part of the roof on top of it
without actually going completely off
grid or making the building asymmetrical
it does make things a little bit more
tricky when it comes to getting things
exactly in the middle or decorating the
roofs or things like that but in general
I'm quite happy with how it turned out
and it's a bit of course perspective
that I really wanted to try so that's
the very basic shape of the bit of the
building it's very simple it's heavily
inspired by many Japanese tea houses I
would say it's also one of the most
realistic buildings in a sense that it
doesn't do anything
ridiculous or makes any different styles
it's a completely Japanese building but
I still wanted to make it somewhat
unique so it's got much more decorations
on the roof and on the walls and many of
the tea houses that you would find like
this is based on the general kind of
layout of a tea house where you have
these corner roofs and you have a second
floor with another roof on top of it but
almost all of these tea houses just have
a very simple straight to-the-point
kind of proof very often not even with
curving corners but in this case I
really wanted to add a bit of extra
detail and personality to the building
so I took the old roofs and changed them
up a little bit and put them on top of
the building and I'm quite happy with
how that turned out it's pretty simple
in terms of the shape of the building
but it took quite a bit of work to get
the kind of shape that I was hoping for
and figuring that would work in the
entire area because this being the
garden part of the agent section as well
I wanted to get a building in here which
would kind of fits in to the surrounding
area without being too dominating over
it I think there is always this thing
about Asian architecture where it's
completely different from Western
architecture because it tries to live in
harmony as much with nature as it can if
that doesn't sound too cliche and
Western architecture just usually screws
nature over and just builds all on top
of it and is a lot less modest in a way
so this building I wanted to have
something that is small enough to fit
into the garden kind of area that I have
here so that it would actually fit into
the gardens and not feel too out of
place in it but it was also supposed to
be quite small because it is sitting
right in the middle of this really busy
area with a lot of water and a lot of
paths that I wanted to keep quite open
because it is sitting right in front of
the roller coaster and it could look
quite a few views if it was too big so I
had to keep it quite small for that as
well and since it is a tea house and
since it is just supposed to be sort of
like taking part in the garden rather
than
like one big attention drawing thing I
also wanted to keep it quite simple and
go more for a japanese-style without too
many colors without the paint on the
outsides instead of some sort of very
extravagant Chinese style so this is the
way that it turned out and it's actually
my favorite building in the entire park
so far even though it's really simple
I'm just very happy with sort of like
the idea that I had for it and the way
it was going to have to fit into the
area is more or less yeah has more or
less worked out exactly the way I wanted
it to but yeah that's the building also
it's pretty funny then it's a teahouse
but it's actually a burger restaurant
functionality-wise
just because there is no tea kind of
strolling the game and burgers were the
next best thing I guess since I didn't
have many burgers around here and we do
have the Burger Kong and pretty close
proximity so if you're into burgers you
can actually go to the Asian area for
some reason which is pretty weird
I'm gonna have to outdo that in the
American area somehow probably but um
yeah moving on we have a couple of
tables and chairs and there are
basically four kinds of areas where I
wanted to put tables and chairs for this
small teahouse it's really one of those
self-service kind of places where you
just get whatever simple kind of fast
food you have and sit down somewhere in
a nice picturesque area and as for the
picturesque areas I wanted to make sure
to have quite a few of them here since
this is a very important or a good
looking point to look at the rest of the
park from which I'll show off in the end
of this video but basically I had to
keep some areas around this tea how it's
very open to not only keep the tea house
very visible but also have some nice
areas where you could sit down and enjoy
some views of the park and the first
kind of view points the avenue to have
is run along that curving path just
because it gives you a great view of the
coaster another one are some tables
underneath the roof of the building just
because that kind of works as well and
the third one which I'm working on right
now is one that I kind of hoped to do a
little bit more in the future it's a bit
further away from the rest of the area
and it's not that much in the Asian area
anymore really but it's right next to
the lake which gives you a pretty good
view over the lake and in the future
when we have all of the different areas
when we can actually see the European
area and see the American area and the
main street of course from the lake that
should hopefully be a pretty good view
to be sitting alongside the water as
well it's kind of inspired by like a
small seating area next to the lake in
the efteling where you can see like all
of the rollercoasters and everything in
the park and it's that kind of feeling
and that kind of a more like relaxed
part of the theme park where you can sit
down and and eat some stuff but where
you can also just look at everything
that's going on in the theme park see
all the roller coasters and the scenery
in the distance which is what I wanted
to do for this small area and I'm saying
small because I really don't have that
much space left here I could have
expanded it quite a bit but the European
area is gonna be very close to where I'm
building this right now and I don't want
to make it too large still save some
space with a very big console which you
can have in the European area which is
absolutely going to loom over the rest
of the park so it is just a very small
section of tables and chairs here but
it's probably my favorite part where I
would love to be sitting and just kind
of look at these surroundings tables and
chairs are all just kind of the same I
might switch them up a little bit and
they're kind of simple themselves as
well but I hope to probably switch them
up a bit depending on the areas you
could also see me kind of building a
parasol kind of thing for a little bit I
decided to give up on that idea just
because I couldn't build a very good
Paris or but I might still make a couple
and put them over some kind of
restaurant areas in the future because
they do not only look good and give that
kind of restaurant vibe to an area but
it's also just you know functional you
don't want to be sitting in the Sun or
the rain all the time now last but not
least we have a small part where you can
sit which is right in front of the
building itself which I guess is for
lazy people and if you don't want to
walk too much to get your food over to
place where you want to eat I guess this
is the place where you want to go but
also I wanted to keep this part very
open since if I would have already felt
this
with the building or some foliage there
isn't really any kind of angle from
which you can look at the teahouse
itself from this part of the park and
because of the way that this is now a
bit more open and you have these tables
and chairs if you approach this area
from the European area you're going to
be able to see the tea house and
actually see everything kind of pan out
in the distance behind the tea house and
that's kind of the way that I wanted to
work out if you walk into this area and
having some foliage around here very
quickly would have probably made the tea
house too hidden among the forest so
yeah I wanted to keep that open
but everything was looking very open and
boring at this point so I wanted to
close things off a little bit more and
make things a bit more interesting and I
figured a good way to do so would be to
add some trellis above these tables
which I have here which kind of make
this very wide winding path a bit less
wide and intimidating but it also kind
of helps to make this part a bit more
interesting because you have the facades
with the buildings on the right side and
we have to see how it's on the left side
here but in the middle there was just
this boring bamboo like fence which
wasn't really all that good-looking or
interesting and kind of like an empty
dad gap between the two facades so I
wanted to fill that in with some trellis
to make it a bit more interesting so
that's what we're going for you but I
didn't want to end up making it too busy
since it is still are pretty important
parts to look at the rest of the park
from so it's just that one side of where
I wanted to add some work over the
tables and aside from that they're all
pretty much just out in the open and
last but not least in this video I want
to add some path essentials I don't
think I'll be making any new ones just
taking the existing lanterns and benches
and planters and putting those around
everything but especially in this area I
didn't really have any of those signs of
life here at any of those barrels or
pots and planters that just add a bit of
extra detail to the empty areas of the
paths or to the empty parts of building
fronts so that's what we're doing here
and yeah I also wanted to add all sorts
of like random stuff around the paths
just to make them a bit less empty and
boring it's something which I always do
last though and sometimes I just even
forget about doing it because it's the
very last thing that you do whenever
everything else has already finished
just because it's kind of a mindless
thing I think just adding lots of random
details wherever you can don't really
have to pay too much attention to it
just filling in some of the empty spots
and it generally just does make things
look a little bit better but it for me
at least can also be a bit distracting
if you haven't really finished all of
your buildings or path work yet which is
why it's always gonna be like one of the
very last things that I'm doing and
while I'm doing that round I also kind
of like to look at all of the buildings
again and just kind of look at them with
a fresh eye because once you've just
built something you're not like your
judgement of it is usually not as good
as when you come back to it a couple of
days later and go like ah I could change
that right there and that is exactly
what I figured for some of these
buildings here a lot of the windows were
exactly the same and I changed a few
already off-screen but there I was just
looking at it and going well I could
change a couple of things here and there
just because it was looking super
repetitive and a bunch of different
kinds of textures and patterns on these
windows and doors should make things a
bit more interesting I was also trying
to get some planters in on the outside
here with that plan didn't really work
out making it myself so I just got a
couple of in-game ones and that works
pretty well and the rest is just kind of
adding a bit of stuff to these buildings
these are some of the most unfinished
buildings though I'm probably gonna do
something with them again in the future
anyway that's it for the time lapse I'm
gonna give it over to my real time self
here to give you a very quick tour of
the pipe so far it's been a while since
I last did an overview like this but I
really want to do it right now because
there's a lot of new detail and smaller
things what you want to take some time
and zoom into and show off what my
entire idea and thoughts behind certain
things were which you can't really show
that well on a
and you definitely can't really take the
time to do it and the first thing that I
want to show off right here is the new
Japanese tea house which I am very sorry
Bogota is probably my favorite building
in this entire area even though it's so
small and not as colorful as the many
more abundant buildings in this area are
I just kind of like how it laid-back and
more charming it feels to me and the
reason why I wanted to go for a tea
house in this case specifically it's
like I said kind of to get something to
fill in this part of the park make sure
that it's not as empty well at the same
time it has that functionality of been a
restaurant which I didn't have yet and
the way it looks right now is basically
like this from this side I wanted to
keep this very open we have a couple of
smaller terraces where you can sit down
and the placing of this one here is not
as interesting as the other ones but it
does keep this area more open so you can
look at the building a bit more and on
the other side we have of course the
bridge from which you can see the
building very clearly and my favorite
angles definitely from here where you
can have really have that feeling of the
gardening around it's the bridge in the
distance and Seeley the wooden parts of
it next to the water
which I'm really happy with how it
turned out and another Terrace that I
wanted to add which is a bit more far
away it's next to the water which
hopefully I'm gonna do a bit more in the
future as well I want to make use of the
lake as much as I can and from here
you'll be able to see the different
areas so we'll have the very big
European kind of Castle part here we'll
have probably some kind of American
temples in here and maybe even the
African part here is gonna be visible no
you sure about that and on the other
hand it just makes sure that we have
this nice like closer to the lake parts
of the Asian area bringing it into the
rest of the park a bit more and last but
definitely not least we have the part
which is right underneath the trellis
here which is not too big but I'm like
this this felt like the most important
part of this area to me because it's
apart from which you can see almost
everything from the Asian area and which
is kind of like the part where you're
going to want to take hoyer pictures
from innocence we have the facades on
the side right
with the fancy toilet building and
giving you the backdrop of the gates
towards the Arabian area then we have
the coaster on this side interacting
with the terrain and all the way on the
other side we have the pagoda and the
much bigger stuff behind the gardens and
you can almost see everything in the
entire area just from here like one big
panorama and that's why I wanted to put
a bunch of benches and tables and make
sure to keep this is open and keep this
entire kind of panoramic place as as
photo take a bow as I can if that makes
any sense and of course it kind of also
works from the other side we have the
view of the tea house from the bridge
over here and you can walk underneath
the coaster kind of having that big
jungle of steel above you the only thing
that I'm slightly worried about is that
there's no real protection against the
coaster realistically I definitely want
to have some coaster nuts around here
but there's nothing right here and while
I could well quite easily make some kind
of simple coaster net underneath this
parts the curves over here are very
close to the coaster in an emesis kind
of way but this path is way more busy
than the queue of nemesis and I'm not
really sure how much I like that I think
I'll just take form over functionality
here and just leave it kind of dangerous
just because I like the way it looks but
it's one thing then I would probably say
is a flaw of the way that this entire
thing is laid out what else is pretty
important is of course this view from
the lake which is like the biggest most
important view of the area and where you
can really see it kind of shaping up and
we have the paths over here where if you
go to this part of the park you're gonna
have to walk up to this part here and
get pretty much the best view of the
hill with the pagoda and the buildings
but if you take like the lower path we
have this big panorama over here where
you can like really turn around and see
all of the buildings this is gonna be
the future station so that's hopefully
gonna look fine in the future as well
you can have all of the buildings in one
big wide shot as well and on the other
side the first thing that I'm gonna do
in the next episode is get a building
around
as long as there's a wall with a bit of
foliage to close this off here just to
make sure that everything is balanced
that it doesn't look like we just have a
big hill here and nothing on this side
and make sure that this is one big cozy
Plaza that kind of feels like you're in
the middle of Asia and after that if
that's finished and the station is done
then the entire area is pretty much
finished and we can move on to what is
most likely going to be the next area
and which is going to be the European
part with the castle so thank you guys
for watching this episode I hope to see
you guys next time in which I'll start
working on the building here and maybe
even the station bye bye